good morning to you at patsy um first of
all start by telling us
in your words what exactly happened on
saturday evening
oh yeah thank you for having me um i
think you know it did start as a vigil
people wanted it to be
peaceful and safe but it did turn out
you know the opposite of what we wanted
um
it just it was a bit of a whirlwind to
be honest what was the atmosphere
like initially and then what did it
become
at the start when we first arrived it
was peaceful people were laying
candles and flowers i had a candle
myself that i didn't actually get to lay
down
because it escalated so quickly um but
you know
people were speaking through a
microphone uh through you know a speaker
but they they had to project their
voices
um and i think you know i don't know
whether that came across as slightly
aggressive or something but
yeah it just progressed from there and
what exactly were you
doing when you were arrested
i was standing against um a gate so
basically the
the police the police came onto the band
stand
with us and some of the well at first i
wasn't on the bandstand but someone said
to come on
because um like women were being
aggressively spoken to and we wanted to
make sure everyone was safe
so we you know some people moved flowers
out of the way to make sure that they
weren't trampled on
and we went on to the band stand and
then all of a sudden there was a lot of
police on the bandstand
um because of the amount of police we
had to we were sort of forced
towards a barrier um and at one point
you know i saw
the woman next to me there was a police
sort of put his arm around her throat
and was trying to pull her backwards so
we were we were very scared about what
was going to happen
um there was someone in front of me
telling me not to
give them my name or anything so i've
never been in a situation like this
before so i just thought well if i just
don't say anything i'm not sure what to
do
um but you know i just stood there and i
know someone was
a police officer was pulling my arm
trying to get my name
and then all of a sudden i was tackled
to the ground so
yeah we're looking at the um shots now
of you being
arrested so what did the police officers
actually
say to you as they were taking you away
[Applause]
um they well as i was being taken away
behind me one of the police officers um
that was holding on to me i believe it
was him
um was saying i've got my hand on my
baton i've got my hand on my baton to
one of the other officers
and i thought this is so like terrifying
because we're about to walk into a crowd
of people
and i don't know whether that crowd are
gonna like
like go against what's going on and me
being arrested i had no idea
um so i was worried for the safety of
others and i did say to the crowd i said
he said he's got his hand on his back
and just be careful
um and then they said she's antagonizing
the crowd please move her back
i wasn't trying to antagonize anyone and
just make sure everyone was safe
i'd say in the shots that we're showing
you don't look terrified what what was
going
through your your mind
to be honest i i was terrified um but
then when i looked up at the press
i had um a small thought of like if this
gets out um you know i might be
um you know interviewed or something and
to be honest
in that moment the fear didn't really
matter to me
and i think we need to direct it away
from the police
and actually towards the the matter at
hand and the issues at hand which is
the safety of women we now have a voice
and we need to
progress this and make sure that women
are heard and there's a dialogue open
now
just one more on the the vigil obviously
the the initial
visual that was planned by reclaiming
streets was officially
cancelled um why did you then go down
i think people were angry because if um
if it wasn't cancelled you know the
organizers did try and make it a safe
event we wanted
um police there and for it to be
controlled and safe for everyone
because women just wanted to you know
share their experiences and
show solidarity with one another because
you know we all go through it
and um we can all relate to things um
that that was happening
to each other and to be honest um you
know when
the police said it's not allowed to go
ahead i think people were just annoyed
and said
you know all we want is a space to a
safe space to
mourn and and and you know and be
with each other yeah as you say it was a
vigil and
one of sarah everard's friend she's
written a piece saying that she thinks
sarah would have been
unsettled at how her death has been
politicized
helena edwards is her name and she says
her killing has been
hijacked and it's not a tribute to her
anymore can you
understand that sentiment why she she
will feel like that in her grief
yeah of course fully um you know no no
one intended this it was meant to be a
vigil
all we wanted to do is pay respects this
um you know
i i accidentally went viral i didn't
want
you know i didn't this happened like a
whirlwind
you know i don't i i thought about it
and i thought you know
i have been thrown into sort of the
public eye um
and the only way that i can make
you know make this not in vain is to
just from this
not make it political not make it um you
know against the police or against
anyone
it literally is just about the safety of
women and we need to just talk about it
you decided not to go to the um the
gathering the um
much from parliament square yesterday
why was that have you
rode back from your initial feelings
um there are a few reasons um you know
and
i i don't think it's safe for people to
go
um but you know there's not much more
that i can say about it at the moment
um unfortunately you don't think it's
safe for people to
to gather in numbers
i just i just hope people are going to
be safe
you've used the hashtag stand in
solidarity on social media
what is it now that you're hoping people
will go on to do
like i said it's a dialogue and i think
we need to come together as a society
men and women to talk about what's
happening
um you know change um
the the system of women not and having a
voice and not being safe to walk down a
street um
and it needs it it just needs to keep
going forward and
the education it just needs to be like
everyone needs to educate themselves on
how they can change things
but you're not advocating gatherings or
any protests in that form
um personally i can't speak on it at the
moment but
you know i i do post on twitter about it
so